no SATs no hair and makeup no costumes
no fancy trailers
yeah these films did what many great
films do they made us feel mmm so true I
remember crying my eyes out when I
watched the end of the Lion King how old
are you not important
wait you were like 20 years old let's
just all move on Thank You Zoe
okay the fact is these movies made us
feel with paint and pixels and often
years of incredible hard work and effort
it is no surprise that animation is
hollywood's most successful and
innovative genre these are the nominees
for best animated feature film big hero
6 Don Hall Chris Williams and Roy
Connolly the boxtrolls Anthony stocky
Graham animal and Travis Knight how to
train your dragon 2 dean deblois and
bonnie arnold song of the sea' Tom Moore
and Paul Young the tale of the princess
kaguya a South Dakota and Yoshiaki
Nishimura the Oscar goes to the honors
I love Lily thank you
big hero 6
we'd really like to thank the Academy
for honoring our film congratulations to
all our fellow nominees this has been an
amazing year
for animated films and we are privileged
to be in your company thank you to
everybody at the Walt Disney Studios
especially mr. John Laster the best boss
in the world
absolutely absolutely to the cast and
the crew see her right baby to the cast
and the crew of big hero 6
thank you for your talent thank you for
your passion you guys put your heart and
soul into this movie and we are forever
eternally grateful to our wives thank
you guys Astrid marry my Deniz thank you
guys so much for supporting us while we
got to live out our dream every day once
upon a time there was a freckle-faced
little boy who told his mom and his dad
that one day he was going to work at
Walt Disney Animation and they did
something amazing they supported him and
they believed him and from the bottom of
his heart he thanks them thank you
marry